so let me tell you that story about
Christopher Columbus please
so the Dec story ever told you the dick
story yeah now let me tell you just
something else okay okay I think him
coming to America was the most
significant thing to ever happen in our
species whoa
silence not an internet porn well that's
just porn in another medium right Wow
yeah so yeah internet porn is just a
matter of degree not a matter of yes
does it exist or does it not right okay
I think it was the most significant
event to happen in our species kind of
amazing when you stop and think about
the fact that at that point in time
other than the Native Americans who
lived here who are living a nomadic
tribal existence very few people that
had the wheel that had firearms that had
all these things that had already been
achieved in the rest of the world had
made their way to this place so don't
watch okay
here's how it worked right so you're
gonna hear so I that you have some
skepticism of this claim as most people
would especially the the Columbus haters
who are out there all right I don't
really have any okay so let me let me
describe to you why I think this is true
okay and then you can tell me whether
you agree or not all right
we are hunter-gatherers we haven't
settled down yet the early humans and
we're basically wandering we're
following the herds
all right and then the Ice Age hits well
what is an Ice Age an Ice Age means it
is so cold that when the moisture
evaporates from the oceans goes to the
clouds the clouds go over the land it
doesn't rain it snows and the snow falls
and then it stays so the water that had
lifted up from the ocean does not return
to the ocean
it accumulates on the land and this
accumulation when it's significant and
sustained we call glaciers glaciers is
not itself a snowfall it is compressed
snow that's basically change state into
this this ice river that flows very
slowly back to the ocean but the oceans
are getting drained faster than they're
getting replenished so during the Ice
Age the ocean levels dropped exposing
the Bering Strait land bridge between
Asia and what is now Alaska basically
North America the our ancestors who come
out of Africa go into Europe some stayed
others kept wandering some stayed low
above the Mediterranean others went high
they populate Asia they keep walking
because there's a land bridge there they
don't even know it's a bridge it's just
more land so they walk and they enter
North America from there that's kind of
only way you can go with South at that
point the weather gets a little better
the Ice Age ends the glaciers melt back
into the oceans the oceans level ocean
levels rise closing the land bridge
stranding a branch of the human species
for 10,000 years those humans who made
it across that land bridge and spread
out into North America Central America
South America have only a few families
as their parent genetic as their genetic
origin okay oh it's like that some
research says it's like eight family
lineages populated the entire North and
South American continents then the land
bridge breaks now you have Europe Asia
Africa and North and South America and
they know nothing of one another
two separate branches of the human
species
the Vikings notwithstanding maybe they
found
they didn't time that even if they did
their influence was near zero relative
to the Europeans so we're talking about
influence here this is a branch had this
continued this is how you specie ate
this is why the species on Australia
that's why you have mammals there would
that have pouches alright no other
mammals do that they split off and they
evolved their own way okay so ten
thousand years is not enough to grow
three heads or you know twelve fingers
but our species is separate now Columbus
crosses the Atlantic makes contact with
humans this is the first time that has
happened in 10,000 years we have
rejoined two branches of the human
species we are now one common genetic
group and that genetic crossbreeding and
that continues to this day we fly to any
corner of the world in mates okay and
the mating already began immediately yes
there were diseases that Columbus
brought to North America much written
about that less written is that he
brought syphilis back to Europe first
cases of syphilis of 1492 whoa and then
it yes what did they have no problem
with it well yeah I don't know the
details of how the physiology of the
natives huh dealt with that or whether
it mutated you know I don't and there
may people know that I'm not among them
that's fast but if you just look at you
look at the graph of syphilis reported
syphilis cases in Europe
it all began 1492 when he came back so
what I'm saying is this was a hugely
significant event the rejoining of the
branches of the human species but ya
know I would imagine that that makes
sense that is the most important event
that and by the way Native Americans you
know this famous infamous problem with
metabolizing alcohol okay with Native
Americans you know what else has their
problems the Chinese they do yes really
yes yes
so it's an Asian issue well so
who stayed in it so you look at who
populated North and South America after
the you know before the LAN bridge is
whoever was right at the edge of Asia
right then the land bridges so so Asians
and and North American and and the
natives of North and South America have
more in common with each other because
of this then most other pairs of groups
you might grab around the world but my
point is obviously we there's a lot to
blame Columbus for but he just happened
to be the guy who did it first Europe
was coming to the new world no matter
what that everybody was trying to find a
faster trade route to the Indies and so
if it wasn't Columbus it would have been
Arnold said Nick or whatever it doesn't
matter
somebody did that and the rest is as
they say history Wow
so personally I think it's the most
significant thing to happen in our
species otherwise we'd still be two
stranded branches of humans it would be
fascinating though like Australia
stranded to see what would happen if it
this has gone on for hundreds of
thousands of years we have a hundred
thousand that would have been a
different story right yeah and your
immunities would be different your yeah
well that